let me get to Darren Revell the sports
business reporter senior executive
producer for Action Network is a most
recent article Jordan Brand make
necessary bed wasai on Williamson's shoe
deal and Darren joins us now how close
to this come to him not going to the
Jordan Brand not going to Nike I was I
heard and that the other major major
deal I mean listen you know I don't
think adidas with harden felt like they
had money to spend you know and his
ridiculous deal Under Armour is looking
to undo deals because they just don't
have the money so those guys were pretty
much out kuma was in the game I heard
the most legitimate offer was that
actually from a Chinese company anta and
we're basically those guys were
basically willing to give him that the
key is to their entire organization but
you know ultimately and that was for
more money but ultimately you know he he
felt the Jordan Brand was right you know
he's he's a Jordan fan and I think you
know going with a a Chinese brand is for
a rookie not like a you know someone at
the end of their career it's not
necessarily like a Dwyane Wade's not
necessarily seen as a as a positive I
should say and I don't know if I'm
embarrassed to say this but Kylie Jenner
was with Puma and she switched to adidas
to join most of the family okay now that
I know that I can rest a little easier
this morning the deal is reportedly 70
or 75 million for Zion how involved was
Michael Jordan in this I actually don't
know I I will say that the rules kind of
stipulate that that we say that he can't
be involved with anyone doing any of
these deals even though there's a
disproportionate amount of Charlotte
Hornets over the years who have not
seemed to be Jordan Brand people who got
Jordan grant deals right like so that's
the concern from the NBA like is there
any salary cap violations going on and
you know for that reason they kind of
say hey you know Jordan can't be talking
to people yeah as I ins probably going
to be locked
with the pelicans for you know four or
five years at least on this really deal
but but I would say that you know I'm
sure there was a deal sealer kind of
thing like jay-z with his sports agency
but I wouldn't expect he would be that
involved certainly because of the rules
I mean I think the most interesting
thing about this because I've been
covering shooting Ossetians for twenty
years there's one thing that's the part
of this deal that has not been part of
any other deal which is that you have
the shoe below the Nike shoe blow up on
the biggest regular-season game of the
year against North Carolina the
most-watched game it's not like just
this like you know brand negativity it's
your actual product you know blew up on
the biggest player in the in the game
and so that I think made more money for
Zion oil set because if he didn't design
with a Nike company you could imagine a
eat in there Puma would say hey yes why
don't we make a commercial about the
blow-up and if he did obviously it helps
them save face so that that provided an
angle that we'd never seen before
Darren Revell joining a sports business
reporters senior executive prude Center
for Action Network how much is Michael
Jordan make in a year
I believe his current deal is and they
haven't ever confirmed it five percent
of the gross royalty so he's he's at
probably a hundred and thirty to 150
million a year right now some people
would say is a bad deal by the way I
mean like yes he needed Nikes engine but
you know I mean a lot of it is him you
know some people might say hey you know
given the power where he was at could he
has been the only guy to kind of do his
own shoe company and and you know then
he keeps more of that but ya know he's
he's clearing 130 million a year yeah I
know that you're working on a story
about Adrian Peterson the Redskins
running back he made over a 100 million
dollars in his career but I guess he is
bro
bankrupt how did he lose his money I
think some of it is stupidity you know
obviously you know I was told he spent
millions of dollars on his 30th birthday
party you know there was an ESPN story
about the account of that where he had
camels and lemurs and flew everyone in
first class and you know it's his lawyer
is telling a story of you know more like
you know bad apples and people that he
tended to trust and whatever but you
know some of it's got to be on m2 he
spent money frivolously you know and I
don't I hate to make this about the
NFLPA but you know they have this
financial advisors program Dan which
basically allows people who are in or
financial advisors if they're you know
seven years in the field or so they can
take a test and become NFL certified
financial advisor through the Union and
the problem is that although they don't
tell the guys to go to these guys they
you know parents and and the kids you
know the athletes say are you certified
and you know sometimes people who are
certified who happen to take the test
are a lot less reputable than a Morgan
Stanley guy who doesn't feel like taking
the test but manages 700 700 to a
billion dollars in people's money so it
kind of creates this false sense of
security I don't think they should be
doing that type of program and you know
so I think that there's the negative
there too but yeah this is just but we
don't we don't know Darren if Adrian
Peterson use these people you're talking
about do we know we do know that
so in when I was still when I was at
ESPN I looked at his charity and you
know I found that the main benefactor of
his charity for a period of four years
was the treasurer of his charity so
there's been things over time that's
been you know really really bad
decisions and there's been a lawsuit or
two over people that have had uh you
know advised him but how much is
is fault and how much is their fault I'm
sure that's going to come out what we
know now how we know he's broke is that
he was lent 5.2 million dollars by
someone and he's paid zero of it is
there any who are some of the other
advertisers going after Zion you know
after Jordan Brand is there
McDonald's who's the night that's like
the old way of thinking of it what I'm
interested to see is obviously in the
day and age where you now have athletes
as companies you know where you have
LeBron and what he does with his deal
with Warner Brothers and Turner you look
at Kevin Durant has his own media
company you know you wonder what he's
going to keep for himself I don't think
it's going to be a lot of these one-off
five hundred thousand and two million
dollar deals I think he's going to want
to own something and own a piece of
equity of a company and so I think
that's going to be different how much is
he going to go to you know Silicon
Valley and and do what others have done
I think that's the new model so instead
of thinking of you know what's a product
you're there if he does do a product
he's going to get a piece of the action
Darren good to talk to you as always we
appreciate your time
all right that's Darren Revell Sports
business reporter senior executive
producer for Action Network for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]